But something that Linda said kind of stuck out to me more than anything else is she shared
a story, if you guys haven't watched that interview, it's an awesome interview.
She shared a story of a business owner that she was going back, she was doing the process
with, right?
She was going, everything was going good and she was supposed to do the Zoom call later
that day.
In fact, I think it was the same day, I think it was Thursday before the call.
This business owner hit her up, like many of these business owners do, and said, hey,
can we actually just reschedule the call, right?
Can we reschedule the Zoom call, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, which is what a lot of them
will do.
Linda said that she's had a tough time in the past, but she's like, I'm tired of getting
walked on.
I'm tired of people yanking me around.
She literally told the guy, she's like, I'm working exclusively with one company.
I'm interested in working with you.
I think her exact phrase was like, if this is important to you, we need to talk today.
We need to talk today.
Because she was bold and she meant it and the guy knew she wasn't messing around, the
guy rescheduled, which we don't know if he actually had something or what, it doesn't
matter, but he rescheduled whatever he had that was keeping him from that call.
He pulled over, they did the call, and she inked the deal.